it's claimed that women need feminism
because there are women that suffer
injustice
but this ignores that nearly all human
beings suffer injustice at some point in
their lives at the hands of either men
or women
and justice for only one group of
society to the exclusion of another
is like a bird without one wing it just
doesn't fly
men have a fundamental need for justice
just the same as women do
and whilst the very word feminism
discriminates the word justice doesn't
justice means giving people what they
deserve or merit but as we'll see
feminism and justice are not synonymous
feminism is a highly ambiguous term
straight jacketing is still of
liberating
it is the call for gender privilege
masquerading as equality in essence
feminism denies a human reality it is
unclear
and not the cause for justice to begin
feminists advocate that women have
traditionally been dehumanized in a
male-dominated society which they call
the patriarchy and that it has always
been better to be a man
but this one-sided claim snubs the
privileges that women have often enjoyed
simply for being women
the dynamics of society at the most
basic level show that it has actually
always been better to be a woman
biologically
every woman counts in reproduction and
perpetuating life itself
giving each woman an intrinsic worth
regardless of what she does
it only takes one man however for many
women to have children
so historically this gave rise to the
idea amongst human societies that men
are largely disposable
whilst every woman is indispensable this
is why
instinctively we prioritize safety and
comfort for women rather than men
why women are rescued first in any
emergency or disaster and get the first
seat in lifeboats
why men tend to work longer hours
risking life and limb
in the more dirty and dangerous jobs
like being coal miners oil drillers foot
soldiers construction workers rubbish
collectors
and the male relative acting as the
unpaid bodyguard in the home
to quote one activist women are human
beings whilst men are human doings
this privilege is not appreciated by
feminists because as pro-feminist
michael kimmel once said
privilege is invisible to those who have
it
when it comes to violent crime the
reality is that the more violent the
crime
the more likely the victim is to be a
man men are more than twice as likely to
be murdered than women in the uk
when it comes to domestic violence the
guardian reported that men are the
victims
more than 40 of the time excluding
unreported cases
and men are half as likely to tell
anyone about it in the first place
when it comes to the provision of
refuges there are 7
500 for females in england and wales but
only 60 for men
as for male rape victims within uk
prisons there's a collective state of
denial it's just not taken seriously
men are held to a higher standard of
self-defense and so they often suffer in
silence reluctant to be re-victimized
by an unsympathetic legal system or
disbelieving treatment from
professionals
yet feminists generally remain
egregiously quiet about male suffering
as a result of
social roles whilst feminists seek
liberation from the shackles of the
traditional female role
the man is still expected to continue
his traditional disposable role
this one-sided narrative of feminism is
not the way
forward for feminists equality is merely
a facade to favor women
often at the expense of others like when
former equality minister harriet harman
a feminist publicly requested employers
to discriminate against white men and
hire women instead
if both candidates were equally
qualified or when former equality
minister patricia hewitt also a feminist
was found guilty of breaching the sex
discrimination act by overlooking a
strong male applicant for a job in
favour of a weaker female applicant
the feminists claim to seek equality and
call for a 40
minimum female quota on management
boards but conspicuously do not call for
a 40
minimum quota for soldiers prison guards
lumberjacks miners bodyguards or
construction workers
why is that why not campaign for an end
to the women and children first quality
and lifeboats
and have it first come first though why
not have women and men compete side by
side in the olympics
as equals of course the reason feminists
won't advocate this is because it's not
really about equality but the means to
achieve gender privilege
another shocking example is the feminist
campaign for closing women's prisons
the faucet society the uk's leading
feminist campaign for closing the
inequality gap between women and men
campaign that female prisons did not
suit women's needs
so as recommended in a report by
baroness corsten they should be closed
and replaced with what is in effect
women's social clubs where female
offenders get to spend time with each
other
organizing their own shopping budgets
and cooking and then go home to their
children at the end of each day
the course during report also stated
that women and men are different
equal treatment of women and men does
not result in equal outcomes
going on to claim that women are
governed by hormones in a monthly cycle
which affects their moods and emotions
these biological factors have a direct
bearing on the way in which women
experience stressful events during their
lives if a man was to say that about
treating women differently in the
workplace he'd be called a misogynist
strangely though feminists are
completely happy for women to say that
women
are governed by hormones and biological
factors when it comes to obtaining
privileges
so for feminists male criminals are to
be punished to the full extent of the
law
whilst female criminals should get
comfort and help why is male suffering
and injustice
less important than female suffering and
injustice
surely justice doesn't discriminate but
as we can see feminism does
feminists are not asking for equal
treatment but special treatment
gender privilege women do not need
gender privilege and therefore they do
not need feminism
in reality they along with men need
justice a comprehensive justice for all
secondly women need clear solutions but
feminism is
unclear and evasive feminism comes in
many different factions
conservative liberals socialist
post-modern eco-feminism and so on
with no shared value system or moral
guidance
feminists don't agree on anything but
the name and will happily contradict
themselves if need be for example
feminists have no clear position
on the sexual objectification of women
some feminists advocate androgenizing
the female appearance and others
campaign for safer
uh cosmetic surgery without challenging
why women actually feel the need to have
it in the first place
because feminism cannot deal with
complexities it promotes the idea of
individualism instead
the idea that women should be empowered
through redefining their own
expectations
and feminists are always on hand to
dictate that women should make
men benchmark these expectations instead
of freeing women from male expectation
feminists expect free women to be male
finally i argue that feminism denies
human reality
it straight jackets women and doesn't
understand or accommodate the natural
proclivities of the genders
virtually all species from bees to
primates have different gender roles
with different biological abilities
across the sexes
yet feminists insist that any gender
difference between humans is invented
and there is nothing biological about
men or women that should inform their
social roles
scientific studies have clearly
demonstrated however the role of
testosterone
in building muscle increasing
competitiveness confidence and
risk-taking
making men better suited to the more
hazardous and competitive roles of
society
because of testosterone men naturally
tend to be faster bigger possess more
stamina and are physically stronger
so teaching a girl that she can
naturally compete equally with men
in everything is misleading one
absurd example of this is when feminists
attempting to achieve equal outcomes
between the sexes
had the strenuous physical tests for uk
firefighters lowered and the standards
relaxed in order to accommodate more
female firefighters so the standards you
can now expect from professionals in
burning buildings and boardrooms as i
mentioned earlier
whether male or female is much lower
than before because of feminists
it seems feminists are implicitly
agreeing with plato when he said that
women should be treated equally to men
except that not so much should be
expected of them
leading feminists in their absurd quest
for equal outcomes between the sexes
to campaign for mediocrity in the
workplace rather than meritocracy
feminists argue that the division of
labour in traditional families
constrains women's opportunities
that women are discriminated against in
getting jobs and wages that there exists
a wage gap between the genders
however these arguments collapse upon
further scrutiny because
if employers could get already paying a
woman less for the exact same task that
they could pay a man
why wouldn't they just hire women
furthermore statistics cited by
feminists as evidence of the wage gap
tend to lamp full-time hours in with
overtime hours of which women tend to do
far less than men
they also average earnings from
disparate jobs like primary school
teachers with investment bankers sales
engineers with chemical engineers
hr executives with finance executives so
they don't compare like-for-life jobs at
all
nor are women discouraged from entering
higher paying fields
they outperform men at university but
are more likely to choose languages arts
and social sciences which pay less
whilst men are more likely to choose
engineering technology math and sciences
which pay more
the division of labor once children are
born also means mothers tend to
intensify their home commitments
and fathers tend to heavily intensify
their work commitments
men seem to make this trade off more
than women perhaps because men feel more
obliged to earn than women do
the reality is that the statistics do
not reflect discrimination but choices
if there is a glass ceiling it seems
that women are the main architects of it
because they get to trade off
higher paying jobs for more flexible
hours to combine work and family life
which means they don't only get the
benefit of the father's wage but also a
better work-life balance for herself
isn't that more important than
arbitrarily chasing the highest paying
jobs
feminists don't want to be thought of as
sexual objects but seem happy to be
valued according to their economic birth
both assessments are materialistic and
neither should dictate the worth of a
man or a woman
the wage gap is telling in that
feminists cannot deny the impact of
motherhood on the woman's life choices
that men and women cannot live lives
completely autonomous from one another
that men and women actually need each
other to make a whole
so that's the wage gap but if feminists
are so keen on equality
what about their silence on the cancer
research gap the education gap the
violent crime gap the death on the job
gap the suicide gap
the life expectancy gap all of which
discriminate against men
in idolizing the male and trying to
create an androgenous sexuality where
men and women are virtually identical
except for their anatomy feminists have
perpetuated a misogynistic self-loathing
for the traditional female role
motherhood and female tenderness is now
viewed as a weakness
the strength of men which can be used
used to lead wars just as it can be used
to be fierce protectors
is often kept in check by the compassion
and temperance of women
but when women abandon these qualities
and want the same aggression that they
perceive in men
what will be left when feminists are
insisting on taking over the male role
is it any surprise that men are shirking
their responsibilities which they once
did with pride
diligence and selfless duty if feminists
want to have it all they will most
likely end up having to do it all often
at the expense of their own well-being
and most importantly at the expense of
our children in islam men and women
and their actions are equal in the eyes
of god god says in the quran
never will i allow to be lost the work
of any worker among you whether male or
female
one of you is as the other islam
primarily addresses men and women the
same
because men and women by and large share
the same human characteristics and it
addresses them separately in relation to
the few areas where they differ
the islamic system isn't based on
selfish individualism but a god-centered
worldview promoting mutual reciprocity
in islam women do not serve men and men
do not serve women
rather we serve god by helping each
other and giving to each other based on
human needs
with the understanding that humans are
not all the same
islam guards the female from the moment
she enters the world by rebuking and
prohibiting the practice of female
infanticide
as one of the greatest crimes to be
committed such religion can only go
on to challenge the ill treatment of
women and secure her well-being at every
stage of her life
through property rights marriage
contracts political participation
inheritance laws and dress code it
advocates complementarity with men
rather than competition
marriage is the bedrock of family life
in islam and the fundamental unit of
islamic society
giving us rights and duties over one
another as a wife
she has the right to be provided for
including her own living space
and is guaranteed financial safeguards
should her marriage not work out
yet islam does not straight jacket women
it allows women to enter the workplace
but not
out of the necessity of the struggle to
support herself but out of choice
to be pursued at her leisure in islam
nobody has a right over her earnings
however islam mandates that a man's
earnings must be used to provide for the
women of the household
irrespective of whether they work or not
furthermore
as a mother the woman is given
preference for respect over the children
and from the children over the father
such is the esteemed role
that she plays at the heart of the soul
and the family and by extension society
so islam provides a clear natural and
just solution to ensuring justice
for all humans and has no need for
feminism's vain attempts to reinvent the
wheel that islam set in motion over 1400
years ago
in islam power is not a virtue it is a
burden and a responsibility
instead of seeking to empower ourselves
we should seek to empower justice
in islam women are liberated from the
servitude of men and liberated from the
expectations of other women
it is virtue which all human beings
regardless of gender career
or social role can equally strive for
in the end true self-worth and
contentment doesn't come through
submission to any aspect of creation
material men women none of it it only
comes from submission to the creator
himself and all that he commands thank
you